hey guys and welcome to episode number
four of my GE only challenge uh today
we're starting off at about uh well we
hit 300 total level uh last episode our
cash Jack is still only around uh 1 mil
uh but we're going to try to get that up
as quickly as possible because the
buyable skills are going to be extremely
important uh now last episode I did ask
you guys what you thought about having
some more unlockable zones and I really
appreciate all the feedback you guys
gave me although it is a little mix some
people feel like uh I shouldn't really
expand it all and other people I think
the majority would like to see uh
possibly a couple extra areas uh to
unlock a little more content uh so this
is what I'm thinking the sewer system
would be unlocked at 750 total level the
cigm mine uh at 1,000 and I'm kind of
not sure about the uh tree teleportation
or mainly just the gnome stronghold uh
cuz you guys did say it is a little far
away and you guys are correct it's not
really part of the grand Exchange but
that would be pendy I'm not sure about
that one but at least those two that
would mean that the sewer system would
be unlocked at about 40 average
throughout all my skills and the kig
mine would be around 60 all right guys
uh so thanks again for all the support
could we try to hit 300 likes on this
video that would be awesome and yeah
let's get started all right guys uh so
we're starting off the episode with some
flips uh both the Mind shield and armor
Del miter had some pretty good margins
on them but we haven't bought any as of
yet uh the greenman's ale we already
bought four for 45k each uh we're going
to sell those for a 10K profit so about
40K in total uh and what we're looking
to do this episode is definitely want to
get our range up so it's level one
pretty well so far and um we would kind
of like to hit a couple farming levels
uh although I'm still not really sure if
it's worth doing that cuz once I get
construction unlocked I'll be able to
get my farming out very quickly all
right there we go we're just about to
hit 25 strength um I'm going to have to
go and look up everything about these
guards I want to know all their stats
what the most efficient possible way to
kill them I mean they have 22 HP So
eventually I'll be one-shotting them so
then it's going to start stop being a
very good experience but anyway 25
strength all right and I think we're
just about to hit our first farming
level uh this is rather slow and I don't
know what you guys think is it worth
even bothering to uh rake these tree
patches because I think by the time I
actually rake this patch like 350 times
I will have unlocked construction uh but
I'm not really 100% sure on that the
other option is I just continue on with
this grind and then unlock her blor
instead uh what do you guys think leave
a comment um yeah so there's level two
farming we can now Farm molds okay we
actually got a maze random uh not as
exciting as I really want the evil Bob
random I don't know if you can even get
that without fishing but it gives you
650 fishing experience which is awesome
that would get us a couple fishing
levels for sure but anyway we'll
complete this quickly all right uh 60%
rewards pretty average uh we didn't take
a very good route to the center
unfortunately uh but what are we going
to get anything can get I think we can
get like 50 60k from this uh all right
there we go there is 30 strength uh next
I'm not sure if we should go for attack
or defense uh attack would be good
because we're still really inaccurate uh
but defense would be useful because when
we want to get a range and level up a
lot of the armor has a defense
requirement um so I'm not sure all right
um so we're looking for another item to
put in the grand exchange and the jar of
souls looks really promising uh it is
going from about well let's see almost
one 70 to 290 at the Max uh which is
almost 100K margin we might able to get
on there uh so we' already put an offer
in and bought in four of them and we're
looking to sell them off for 245 so
that's great uh the mine Shields we
didn't really make much off of but the
uh Greenman we got about a 40K profit on
so not too bad and um yes you can see we
bought the jars of souls for 171 and
we're looking to sell them for 245 uh
which should be a 2 or 300K profit which
would probably be our best flip so far
uh so because it's item is looking very
promising I think we're just going to
put an offer in for more and they bought
relatively quickly so put an offer in
for 172 and uh go for another two I
guess all right there we go uh we
decided to go for attack first uh so
there's 25 attack I just couldn't handle
being so inaccurate all the time uh the
Super Attack potions do help out a bit
uh but I mean there you just need to get
your attack level up eventually and
we're about 357 total all right so we
decided to go ahead and just get 30
attack uh we could just level up our
defense as needed for rain
uh cuz we can already wear Steed body
which is going to take us all the way
till 25 range so maybe at that point
we'll level up our defense more um but
actually we're also about to hit a
farming level uh it's kind of just a
kick in the face how long it takes to
rake the weeds I mean not only do have
to wait like half an hour for them to
regrow it also takes like 5 minutes to
rake them but anyway there we go there
is three farming uh we're on our way I
guess uh so we're just taking a little
break from the combat grind I like
breaking it up a bit and we're just kind
of slowly chipping away at our Fletching
levels uh but that is going to be 50
Fletching I believe we can now uh Fletch
the maple a short bow uh which will
actually net us a quite a bit of money
from it because Maple is so cheap and
but the bow is actually worth something
so we'll actually be getting probably a
couple hundred K from getting from 50 to
55 I think okay so it looks like we
actually sold the Willow Long bows for
192k uh I think we probably profited a
bit off that not that much though uh the
actual profit won't come until later
levels and I don't know if you can
notice but I did something really stupid
I actually bought
1307 uh Maple logs I meant to buy the
unstrung maple short bow and I go ahead
and try to add a bow string to it I'm
like hm something's not right here uh oh
okay yeah so the maple sh bows
aren't actually coming through uh so
we're just going to leave the offer in
there for now and I guess we'll just go
do something else then all right so
we're upgrading our gear a bit here uh
we just bought a combat bracelet it
actually makes a huge difference I don't
know why I have one of these uh it goes
yeah it me almost doubles my attack
bonus with the sword uh so yeah it goes
from 39 SL to 46 and stab up to 23 yeah
so much better all right so we're going
to take a break from melee training for
now and go ahead and level up our range
uh so we went ahead and bought uh
studded chaps and studded bodies or just
one anyway um and we're going to use
steel darts for now and what we're going
to be training on is the mage of zamra
uh it's just Under the Staircase um in
the verac palace because tracking down
the imps and killing them is really
annoying so I don't really want to do
that anymore and it's nice to actually
have a um something I can train on
that's in a cage so it can't move it's
perfect just Chuck darts at it all day
uh so we're going to kill them and then
hop worlds and then repeat all right so
our introductory range gear is going to
get us um well let's see combat bracelet
on and the darts is going to bring it to
I guess 28 range so not bad all right so
here is the mage of zamak he's trapped
under here and we just got seven range
and 32 hit points uh not bad uh so we're
going to kill him and then hop worlds
surprisingly there is a lot of people
here splashing though which is kind of
annoying uh and he doesn't respawn that
quickly like that's me I killed him
already in this world uh we hop to
another
one uh that being said I think it is
still quicker than tracking down the
imps all right there we go there is 10
range uh we can use black darts but I
think they're kind of expensive uh so
we're going to keep with the steel Dart
and we've actually been telegraphing
them just I don't know why not save a
little bit of money and get a little
magic experience I guess all right there
we go that is uh what why is there a
level 118 splashing here uh I don't know
why there's actually so many people here
I guess it's a popular spot never knew
about that but anyway we're just about
to hit 15 range I think I might actually
go train on guards now because uh this
is actually reasonably slow oh I thought
I had the I thought I had the the random
event that give me the to of knowledge
but there just an imp spawn uh but
there's 15 range I think we may go to
guards now uh so we are drinking ranging
potions and uh but a little more
accurate than I thought it was going to
be we're actually about to hit 20 range
just on the guards and I think this
might be actually quicker because it's
well they have more HP and there's not a
bunch of people splashing on them which
is nice all right so we can now go ahead
and upgrade our gear a little bit uh we
have the koif the studded body and the
studded chaps and oh man I think my
mustache just goes really well with the
range gear uh although the gear kind of
looks bad but anyway there is 38 range
bonus now and 25 range just off guards
uh really starting to speed up now uh we
have the camo top as well we did a
random event uh some people accuse me of
cheating but I swear I was just in a
random all right there we go that we
just hit 28 range and now we can upgrade
to the dorish and crossbow uh which is
going to be nice cuz I the mythal darts
I'm using are a little expensive they're
not too much uh but I really feel like I
need to pick them up where the Doran
crossbow is going to be dirt cheap and I
think I think the XP for hour will
probably be better on the guards all
right so we got the dorin crossbow and
3,000 bone bolts an extremely economical
weapon uh but that's going to increase
our range bonus tremendously and the
bone bolt I'm pretty stoked to try this
out okay there is 30 range um this Doran
crossbow is so much better than the
darts uh for one it costs next to
nothing and we're getting about closer
to 15K an hour uh range experience where
before we're only getting 7 or 8K it's
almost double uh the XP per hour which
is nice okay we're just about to hit
another hit points level uh but the
range levels are coming by very quickly
already at 33 range as well uh but there
is 35 hit points just a little Milestone
and I think we may switch over to the
defensive uh mode because we would like
to get or I guess long range mode uh
just to get some defense experience
because our we're getting about 15K an
hour and even if half that was defense
experience it probably be better than
just meing it and uh we're gotten to the
point where we need to upgrade our armor
but our defense level is too low there
is 35 range uh still levels are flying
by pretty quickly uh and also uh 400
total level which is awesome uh yeah
we're going to shoot for 500 pretty soon
uh but yeah not bad okay so the jar
Souls have finally nearly sold
off um it's just been a long time since
we ended up buying those uh it looked
like a really promising item uh but now
I don't think I'd do it again just
because it's been like 2 days since I I
bought them and we still have not sold
them off so I don't think that's going
to be worth it at all uh we're also
looking at the ancient koif which
actually has dropped down to about 16k
but it seems to sometimes rise up to
like 100k so we're going to give that a
try uh we're going to see if we can
actually just price check the item uh
but we can't so that's kind of
interesting can we even buy it for
50k no so it doesn't seem like anyone's
selling this item or it's just way more
expensive right now but I will put an
offer in for I don't know 20K or
something for the ancient KO H we'll do
16500 and we'll do 30 I think that was a
mistake though I think we meant to put
it in for higher all right next up we're
going to try buying some super attack 3s
um decanting them of course I do have a
lot of videos on decanting on my YouTube
channel if you don't know what it is but
anyway it looks like we're going to get
I think it was about a 20 or 30 GP
margin on each one so about 60k from the
entire flip not bad all right there is
level four farming uh now we can make
the Hammerstone hops uh it's a slow
grind but uh we're getting it done so I
was thinking um there is an alter in the
verac palace which means I can uh
restore my prayer reasonably quickly so
I thought maybe I should go ahead and
just level up my prayer to get uh the
not Eagle ey but the weaker one is
unlocked at level
20 uh six prayer and uh I calculated it
out uh we're going to need about 430 big
bones and it's only
150k roughly uh so not really too
expensive of course of course I don't
want to spend too much money leveling up
my prayer because this is very
inefficient to do it this way uh but
we'll go get some prayer levels as we
can get some more um damage on my range
all right there's 15 prayer uh bearing
these bones is slower than I thought
they were going to be but still about
40K an hour okay we just hit 20 prayer
um we're I just looked it up I
definitely miscalculated the amount of
Bones I need I'm going to need like
another 70 bones after this
unfortunately okay we're just about to
hit 25 prayer and this I had the perfect
amount of Bones almost uh there's 25 and
then all of a sudden I look oh protect
item ah One More Level okay there
we go we're just about to hit 26 prayer
perfect amount of Bones and there we go
we can now use the what is it
Hawkeye yeah Hawkeye prayer which will
give us a 10% increase in my range
damage and accuracy I believe and yeah
so the alter is pretty nearby so we're
going to give this a try and see if it's
actually going to be worth running back
and forth between the alter or not he
okay so we just hit 25 defense and uh
we're using the long range mode on the
crossbow right now uh so we'll actually
be able to upgrade our gear pretty well
um now I have tested using Hawkeye and
ites definitely does increase my damage
uh but I don't think it's worth running
all the way to the altar yet because my
prayer is only 26 only last for like a
minute or two and then I have to come
restore the prayer I think at some point
it definitely is going to be worth it
once I get higher range and prayer
levels uh and or if I prayer flick but I
don't want to do that that but for now I
think we're just going to uh not do it
okay so we ended up buying frog leather
uh for pretty expensive
unfortunately um so those give us a plus
two boost those actually reduced our
range I'm
confused okay so the studded body is
worse but the studded chaps are
better I really don't understand that
why what that's very strange okay well
that confused me so we're taking a break
uh we're doing some wood cutting and
there is 35 wood cutting we also have
been picking up quite a few bird bird's
nests and while the contents aren't
usually worth that much the actual bird
nest itself is about 3 or 4K okay there
we go there's 40 wood cutting um couple
more birds nests and the XP per hour is
about 25k so it's going to take about 10
hours uh till we unlock UT trees so it's
a bit of grind but really not as bad as
some of the other things okay so quite a
few of the flips have come through I
forgot to mention we actually bought
some more blessings as well but we'll
get to that uh so these super attacks we
ended up selling after decanting them
for 45 so that is a 4K profit there uh
not terrible um now the war blessings we
ended up buying for 15K each and I think
we sold them for like 25k each that a
really good margin there uh yeah no 25
and 26k one we actually insta sold for
26k so we got 10K on each uh so about
150k on that which is actually really
nice uh the final jar of souls have come
through as well and and the death
Talisman flip just kind of stalled out
so we are just going to end up dumping
this uh but looks like our cash Jack's
going to be about I guess
1350 uh so we're getting up there but
we're going to go have to find a well
some more consistent and quicker items
I'd say cuz that is quite a lengthy
amount of time it took for that flip to
come through so what we're looking at is
the
obsidian I don't even know it's it's a
weird item it's not the M or the I it's
a it's the tazar c m that one anyway
um but it looks like the margin on it is
very good about 140 to 200 uh and it is
a bit of a rare item so I did say I was
going to do a more in Market item but
we're we're going to do it anyway uh so
it's the sard k m that's the wrong one
honestly it kind of just looks like they
flipped the model I'm not even sure if
it's a different one I don't know we'll
see yeah look it just looks like they
turned it upside down pretty well oh
well anyway uh we're going to try to buy
this I think for one
41 uh 141 and yeah went up to like 220
so that is really promising uh we're
going to just use all our money on this
and cuz we got to get to work and I
think we're going to go for eight okay
so we're uh kind of not you I'd like to
imagine I was pray flicking the whole
time but I would have not been uh but it
definitely does increase my damage so I
don't know we may continue to do this or
may not but we are still grinding out
some range levels okay so we're just
about to hit 40 range and I think that's
we're going to stop for now uh we do
have enough range to wear the green
Dragonite Set uh but of course we're
never going to get that so we'll have to
wait until 50 range and then we'll be
able to actually equip something good
okay so all of the obsidian enter blank
item name here uh has sold off so we
sold them for 213 each uh 13k each sorry
and uh we bought them for 1,200 and
we're sing selling them for 17 so that
was a huge profit on that item
definitely going to give that another
try 12 8 and we got 1704 backs that's
500k in profit plus we have another 144k
in the bank bringing our total Bank up
to about 1.8 mil uh which is great so
we're definitely going to do this again
151k each another eight sounds good to
me and I think we may find actually one
other item to do as well and I think we
were going to do the skeletal gloves
another reasonably slow item but the
margin is just so good 61k into like
100k uh skeletal gloves we'll try buying
them for well 62k each I guess and we'll
go for 65k and we'll do another eight of
these as well so I think that's where
we're going to end it for today guys I
hope you did enjoy episode number four
of the GE only challenge uh so now we're
going to do a quick recap of what we
have achieved so far uh so our attack
and strength are up to 30 which is
awesome we got our defense to 25 um HP
to 37 and most importantly we got our
range all the way up from nothing to 40
this episode uh and we're probably going
to be capping out and how quick it's
going to be going pretty soon because
the guards are only going to be so quick
at a certain point uh we invested about
150k into getting our prayer to 26
unlocking the Hawkeye spell uh we also
did get our Fletching level up a bit to
50 and our wood cutting to 42 now as far
as our cash stack is concerned I'd say
we're getting pretty close to 2 mil uh
we bought one of the skela gloves so far
and six of the obsidian item and that's
going to yeah it's about 2 mil we have
in cash so yeah we're making really good
progress and I hope you guys enjoyed and
I'll see you guys in episode number five
[Music]